il est assez facile de pénétrer et de
circuler dans grâce à l'axe routier
nord-sud l'artère principale de la ville
longue de 7 km le développement rapide
de la ville s'explique par les trois
activités qui en ont fait la puissance
le bassin houillet l'acier et le textile
comme les villes industrielles sont
souvent grises le comme les villes
industrielles sont souvent grises c'est
un peu le cas de les responsables de la
ville ont organisé des plan de
rénovation urbaine de construction aussi
dans les zones périphériques pour la
petite histoire sachez qu'avec une
altitude de de 517 m et la 2è ville
européenne la plus haute de France après
Madrid elle jouit de 2089h
d'ensoleillement par an